So, we're picking up where we left off last week, and Louisa has been talking about the
ways in which the Lord actually communicates with her.
So, in the next paragraph, we deal with intellectual dialogue.
There are then the two ways that the soul seems to go out of the body, and in these
two ways in which the soul goes out, God speaks to me.
Coming out of the body is an out of the body experience.
Louisa has it almost on a daily basis, and it is completely and totally unusual.
I will try to explain it, she said, but I call it intellectual speaking or intellectual
dialogue.
So that is communication in the intellect direct.
So, as the soul has gone out of the body, finding herself before Jesus, she has no need
for words.
You see, in the spirit world, there's no need for words.
Anyone who's ever had a near-death experience will tell you that once you go into the spirit
world, as soon as you have a question in your head, it is answered.
You get direct knowledge, put infused into your intellect.
That's what she experiences when she goes into an out of the body experience, which tells
you she is out in the spirit world.
So she has no need of words in order to understand what the Lord wants to tell her.
Nor does the soul need to speak in order to make herself understood.
Speaking is a problem that we only need on the planet, on Earth.
It's through the intellect, she said, "Oh, how well we understand each other when we
are together," and she will continuously tell you for many volumes that what she understood
out there, she is not able to communicate when she comes back.
That is a problem that other mystics have had as well.
From a light that comes from Jesus into my intellect, now you know from later volumes
that that light is the divine will.
So it's the Lord infusing directly into her.
But it has been called a light by all other mystics and saints as well, hence the process
is called enlightenment.
So from a light that comes from Jesus into my intellect, I feel everything that my Jesus
wants to make me understand, being impressed within me, that's called infused knowledge.
So write it down, will you?
It's infused knowledge.
So this way is very high and sublime.
And the reason why you would say that is that there's no possibility of interference from
earthly things or from your own human desires or emotions or anything else.
It is pure and direct.
So much so that human nature, my book says nature, you have to say human nature can hardly
adapt itself to explain it with words.
That's her problem when she comes back.
It can barely give a few ideas.
This way of Jesus making himself understood is extremely rapid.
Now I have two Corinthians 12 verses one to four beside that.
Everything in the spirit world is rapid, is instant.
Everything in the higher volumes Jesus calls the low world, that's on earth, everything
is slow and you can't even get through a futile number.
So Jesus makes himself understood, it's extremely rapid.
In one simple instant one learns many sublime things more than by reading entire books.
Now that testimony has been given by other mystics as well.
That you would learn in one minute what would take you four years to study or what a most
ingenious teacher Jesus is.
In one simple instant he teaches so many things that it would take entire years for someone
else if he manages it all because the terrestrial teacher does not have the power to draw the
will of the disciple.
Now notice that the terrestrial teacher can only deliver information to your intellect
but cannot get you to receive it.
They can offer it, they can't get you to receive it.
They don't have the power to draw the will of the disciple or to infuse things into their
minds.
So you see all the time that you're dealing with infused knowledge.
So it's infused knowledge but not with Jesus.
His sweetness, the loveliness of his gesture, the gentleness of his way of speaking are so
great and then he is so beautiful.
Now in all of her writings she describes Jesus as the most beautiful.
Now beauty is of course completely misunderstood because of society out there and the way the
television projects so called beauty.
A person could be very plain according to the way the world describes them.
Beauty is something from the interior radiating out.
And so it's a much higher thing than just having nice cheekbones and everything on your
face is just sort of in proper balance so that the people in the world are impressed.
But it's amazing how people are attracted to a person whose inner being is radiated
through their face and they're actually very attracted to you.
They mightn't want to call you beautiful and yet it's the only word that is.
Now in Louis' writings and you'll find it all over the place in the crucifixion of
Jesus in the hours of the Passion that Jesus says to the Father, "I was the most beautiful
of all."
But of course the whole radiant light of God's glory was shining out through him.
So beauty is that interior thing shining out and if the ladies of the world had that on
top of the physical niceness of their faces they would genuinely be beautiful.
So by the same token you can therefore without distortion say that a man is beautiful.
We're not inclined to say that a man is beautiful we'd say handsome but when we say handsome
we're sort of saying it's something masculine whereas we're not talking about something
either male or female we're talking about the soul radiating out through the body.
So he is so beautiful and Louisa never hesitates calling him beautiful that as soon as the
soul sees him she feels so drawn that sometimes the speed at which she runs after Jesus is
so great that almost without realizing it she finds herself transformed into the beloved.
That's the soul attracted by the presence of God and the soul going out of itself into
God is called ecstasy.
In such a way that the soul is no longer capable of distinguishing her terrestrial being so
much as she identified with the divine being.
And that's John 14 20 to 21.
And it's called union with God you and me Jesus said and I and you who can tell what
the soul feels in this state.
It would take Jesus himself or a soul perfectly separated from the body because in finding
herself surrounded once again by the wall of this body and losing that light which before
kept her submarries the soul loses very much and remains obscured everybody who has ever
gone out of the body either in a near death experience or a next to see all say the same
thing that coming back into the body clouds everything.
It's like it's like you have been in the airplane above all the clouds and glorious sunshine
and then the thing descends to the ground and there's nothing on your rain and clouds
and it's terrible.
They say this is that this isn't the day I had up there as the only image I can give
you of the problem that they have.
So if she tries to say something she can say it only very roughly that's one Corinthians
two nine that the things that the eye has seen and ear has heard and God has prepared
is not possible to actually put into words.
To give an idea I will say that I imagine one born blind who has never had the good that
is the privilege of seeing what is contained in the universe and so for a few minutes had
the privilege of opening his eyes to the light and we're able to see everything that is in
the world.
The sun, the heavens, the sea, the many cities, the many machines, the varieties of flowers
and all the other things that are in the world and who after those few minutes of light returned
to the blindness of before.
Now could he describe distinctly everything that he had seen the answer is no because he's
seen too much in such a short space of time.
It didn't mean that he didn't see correctly but he didn't see it for long enough.
How could he describe distinctly everything that he has seen?
He could only give a rough outline and say a few things confusedly.
Now in volumes one to four that's what Louisa says all the time.
I can only tell you in a confused way.
Now something similar happens when the soul finds herself separated and then back in
the body.
I don't know whether I'm saying nonsense.
How you would say that in our languages I'm not sure if I'm making myself clear.
But just as the poor blind one would remain with the sorrow of his lost sight it is the
same with the soul.
She lives moaning and almost in a violent state because the soul feels always violently
drawn towards her highest good, Matthew 1112.
The kingdom of God suffers violence and the violent or the valiant take it by force.
The attraction towards himself that Jesus leaves in the soul is so great that the soul
would like to remain always attracted to her God.
But this cannot be.
And therefore she lives as if she lived in purgatory.
Now Louisa is not actually exaggerating there.
Other saints have also testified that when they have gone out in ecstasy with the Lord
the pain of having to get on with everyday life with all its pettiness and smallness
and the the sinfulness of everybody around you and all the rest of it becomes almost
unbearable.
And the only language they can use is purgatory meaning dire suffering.
But they use purgatory because the word purgatory means you will see him again.
If they said hell then it means you won't see him again.
So they're using the word correctly.
I add that the soul has nothing to do with of our own in this stage.
In other words it's the Lord that accomplishes this.
Everything is the operation done by the Lord.
Now we come to number two and she's going to talk about intellectual visions.
Now I try to explain the second way that Jesus has in speaking that means in communicating.
Finding herself outside of herself we're in an out of the body experience again.
The soul sees the person of Jesus Christ and that's the vision.
For example as a child or as the crucified or in some other posture and the soul sees
the Lord pronouncing words from his mouth and the soul answers from her mouth.
In other words there's real communication.
Sometimes it happens, this is the type of communication you're going to get in all the
messages once we get to the ones that updates on them.
She actually reproduces the dialogue.
Sometimes it happens that the soul begins to converse with Jesus just as two intimate
spouses would do and that kind of dialogue you're going to get also as we go on.
My book says the speaking of the Lord, the words of the Lord.
The words of the Lord are, you'd have to put, very moderate.
Just four or five words and sometimes even just one word very rarely it lengthens a little
bit.
Now this is only in the introduction.
When you get up to volume 20 and onwards you can have four pages as one message.
So it's in the beginning he starts off by giving her a word, a few words, a sentence
and so on and then gradually he gives her a shorter, what we call the shorter messages
and then the messages get longer and longer and so on.
In other words the soul has to accommodate to the way the Lord is communicating with her.
But in those very few words how much light he introduces into the soul.
Now if you go to Genesis 1-3 you'll get an illustration of what you mean by the few words
of the Lord.
Let there be light and then the person who put the text together said and there was light.
But he only had to say let there be light and in the miracles of Jesus you sometimes
hear him just simply saying I want it, that's all.
And if he wants it, that's it, it happens.
But how much light there is that is introduced to the soul.
Now the light you see is the divine will and it's God himself, John 1-5, God is light.
And so what she's really saying is a sea of light, the soul is enveloped in a sea of
light, that's why she understands so much.
I seem to see a little rivulet at first sight but in looking more closely instead of a rivulet
it's an immense sea.
Such is one word said by Jesus, the immensity of light it leaves in the soul is such that
by chewing it thoroughly, now notice the mixed matter as she uses, you can't chew light,
can you?
No.
Okay.
But body it to chew, it's the message of those words.
Seeing it thoroughly she discovers so many things sublime and profitable for her soul
as to remain astonished.
So many people after an experience of deep ecstasy, I mean they just want to stay close
to the Lord and in prayer for three or four days after it.
They don't want communication with anything else because it's such a sublime experience.
I believe that if all the learned united together they would all remain confused and mute at
one single word of Jesus, isn't that fantastic?
One Corinthians 1, 19 to 21.
Now this way she says is more suitable for human nature, in other words, us who are on
the earth side of things and it can be manifested easily because upon entering herself the soul
brings with her that which she has heard from the mouth of the Lord and she communicates
it to the body.
It is not so easy when it's through the intellect because then there is no way of actually communicating
it to others.
It's ideas and thoughts when it's in the intellect.
Now Louisa says to me I think that Jesus has this way of communicating in order to adapt
himself to our human nature, notice that communicating is a better word than the word speaking.
Do you see it?
Because the word speaking to us means a mouth has been used and physical words have come
out of it.
It's actual communication.
It's not that he needs the word in order to make himself understood but in this way the
soul understands more easily and she can manifest it to the confessor.
If she has heard words it's much easier for her.
In some Jesus acts like a most knowledgeable wise and intelligent teacher who possesses
all the sciences to the highest degree.
Now the word science as it is used in these writings is not the same as our society uses
it.
When we say science we think of a very particular part of knowledge like physics, chemistry,
botanismology and that kind of stuff.
With the Lord science it's a translation of a word and unfortunately I don't know the
word in Italian.
But it means knowledge with understanding, wisdom, knowledge, understanding, counsel,
fortitude, they're the gifts of the Lord.
And when the Lord says something to you he gives it to you with understanding.
If you're in a class with a teacher they can give you knowledge but they might be able
to give you understanding.
So he possesses all knowledge and understanding to the highest degree, naturally because he's
the source of it, that no one can equal him.
But since he finds himself in the midst of disciples who have not yet learned the first
syllables of the alphabet keeping all the other studies within himself he teaches the ABC to
his disciples.
I think that's absolutely lovely.
And my way of saying that is you don't teach trigonometry to a three year old.
They wouldn't enter the primary school for you, would they?
No.
They would simply say it was gobbledygook and it would be.
They need to be an awful lot older than that to get it.
So how good Jesus is, notice the English is wrong there, how good is Jesus is not English,
how good Jesus is, is English.
He adapts himself to the learned and he speaks to them in a very high manner in such a way
that in order to understand him they have to study well what he tells them.
And he adapts himself to the ignorant pretending to be he himself a little bit ignorant and
he speaks in a low manner in such a way that no one may remain on an empty stomach from
a lesson from this divine teacher.
In other words, Jesus adapts himself, all of you who have rare children have learned
how to adapt yourself from cooing at a kid in a pram to communicating at much higher levels
as they moved on was the same thing.
You adapt yourself to the age and the experience of the person.
So the third way, I want you to put a little heading here and the words I'm going to give
you come from St. John of the Cross, substantial words.
You should put it on your book.
Number three, the third way is substantial words.
The third way in which Jesus speaks to me or communicates with me is when in speaking
he communicates to the very substance of the soul.
It seems to me that just as when the Lord created the world that with one word he created
everything so that you have John 1-1 and Genesis 1-1, both of them say the same thing in the
beginning God created.
And in these writings Jesus will tell you that every word of his is a creative word.
But you saw that you see that in the Gospels anyway, that when Jesus said go and wash in
the pool of Silo and the man said I went and I washed and I saw.
So it was a creative, sorry, it was a creative word.
And each word of the Lord is a creative word.
For example, I want to give you an example of a substantial word and I always illustrate
with the person sitting beside me so it's nothing wrong with her.
If the Lord says to you directly in your interior, forgive.
That's not just a command.
He creates the ability in you to forgive, does that make sense?
That's what you call a creative word and it's also a substantial word.
That word "forgive" will remain in you forever.
It will never, ever change and every time you remember it the grace that was given to you
is renewed.
That's a substantial word.
That needs to be explained because many people in charismatic prayer groups say they get
a word from the Lord.
And very often it's nothing whatsoever to do with substantial words.
Nothing whatever, it's a human thing and you can very easily forget.
And I've often said to people in prayer groups, if at the end of the prayer group, and you've
been there for an hour and a half, that you don't remember what was said, no substantial
words were used.
Now do you get it?
Because if a substantial word is used, you remember it forever.
Now I'm not putting down prayer groups, I still talk about messages that the Lord gave
to a group of us, up in Ben Burb in 1973, I can still hear them, I can still feel what
the Lord was saying and I know that it's going to happen.
See a substantial word stays, so all I'm trying to do is illustrate if the thing doesn't stay,
it's not a substantial word, it's actually that simple.
And very often we're trying to help somebody and we're putting our own substance into it
without realizing, but if it's a substantial word, you know it's from outside of you and
it has incredible power.
So he communicates to the very substance of the soul, hence the word substantial.
Do you see it?
It seems to me that when the Lord created the world, at one word, things were created.
In the same way, since his word is creative, in the very act in which he pronounces the
word, he creates in the soul the very thing that he was saying.
Now that's exactly what I've said to you.
Now as for example, Jesus says to the soul, see how beautiful things are, but as much
as your eye can flow over the earth and in heaven, you will never find a beauty similar
to me.
At these words of Jesus, the soul feels a certain something divine enter herself.
Do you see the difference?
Something divine has entered.
The soul remains so very drawn towards this beauty.
And at the same time, she loses attraction for the things of the earth that are not beautiful.
So the substantial word actually makes a change inside of you.
As beautiful and precious things may be on the earth understood, they make no impression
on the soul.
That which remains fixed within her and almost transmuted into her is the beauty of Jesus.
But that beauty she thinks with that beauty she feels invested and she remains so enamored
that if the Lord did not operate another miracle or heart would crack, she says we say the
heart breaks.
But I'm sure there's no difference between breaking and cracking it.
And the soul would breathe her last out of pure love for this beauty of Jesus.
Now all the mystics have said the same thing, that if you have a profound experience of
God in ecstasy, the Lord has to withdraw himself otherwise you will die because that's exactly
the aim of your life is to go out of yourself and into God.
That's paradise.
So if the Lord wants you to finish your life on the earth, he's got a withdrawal.
And that's where you're going to hear Louisa moan for 14 volumes at least that she can't
stand Jesus going away.
The pain is just unbearable because she saw him so frequently and she saw him so completely
as well.
The soul would go out of herself out of pure love and fly into heaven and delight at the
beauty of Jesus.
I myself don't know whether I'm speaking nonsense.
Now that means I don't know whether I'm communicating, which she is, isn't she?
So here we're at the substantial words again.
In order to explain myself better about this substantial words of Jesus instead of substantial,
you can't have substantial speaking, you can have substantial words, okay?
I will say something else.
Jesus said, see how pure I am and you also, I want to find purity in everything.
Now when I was growing up many moons ago in Dublin, purity meant always sexual purity.
In these writings, you're going to hear purity in a much, much wider context.
If I give you a drink of water, and there's a tiny, it's wonderful water, but there's
a tiny bit of contamination in it, then it's impure.
If you listen to an orchestra and one of the instruments is slightly off, you say, "Ugh,
that's desperate."
And that's impurity in sound, do you know what I'm saying?
Now the impurity is that there's something spoiling, something incredibly beautiful.
Have you got it?
Yeah, just tell her what page you're on.
There's something spoiling, something incredibly beautiful.
Now if I come to sexual impurity, then you're talking about the incredible beauty that God
has made in the human being, that we have no idea how magnificent the person is when
the soul is in union with God.
And as far as the Lord is concerned, if that is contaminated in some way to him, it's
horrific.
Now Louise is going to explain this as she goes along as she comes into this understanding.
And this is what you mean by that sin is horrifying.
And the only way I can tell you is that if you have something magnificent and somebody
blots it with a bit of paint or something, it's awfully destroyed.
The entire painting isn't destroyed, but it is in a way, even though the bit of paint
or whatever it's through onto it is spoiling one part of it, but it does spoil the whole
thing.
So purity is going to be a very important issue, particularly in the first four volumes where
we're laying down foundations.
But I like to just sort of widen it slightly in case we just look at it into a narrow focus.
So I want purity in everything.
Now I'm going to illustrate the everything.
One of the things is going to give an enormous amount of attention to is purity of intention.
Can I give you an example of an impure intention?
Now I'm using impure deliberately so that you'll hear that this is wider than you were told.
If I tell all of you that I'm going to fast tomorrow, you see, oh she's great, she's doing
something really holy and all the rest of it.
And then in the back of my mind, I said, well she could use a few pounds as well.
The very fact that I'm saying inside of myself that I could benefit from this fasting means
it is an impure act.
Just eat your meals because you're neither going to lose weight nor are you going to lose
anything else.
You've lost everything.
That's impure and you'll find that one of the things that Jesus condemns most is hypocrisy.
And when you read Matthew 15 and Matthew 23, you see him going after the scribes and Pharisees
tooth and nail.
Why?
Because of the impurity of the way they were worshiping God.
Now can you hear impurity?
They had the right clothes, they had the right job, they were doing the right actions, but
they were serving themselves and making themselves very rich and very powerful, but they were
not actually glorifying God.
Now that's impurity at a very deep level.
Exurity in worship is a very serious matter.
And it's not just in the gospel that this is introduced in the Bible, there's a lot
about this in the Old Testament as well, particularly you'll find it in Psalm 50, where the Lord
says in Psalm 50, what are you doing standing in my presence when you are at home with the
dulchers and you accept thieves and you accept this, that, and the other?
In other words, your so-called spiritual life is totally contaminated, it's completely impure.
Get out of my sight.
And the Scriptures are very clear about the fact, Hebrews 12, 14, nothing impure or unholy
can enter the presence of God, Venetol, just won't.
And in higher volumes, Jesus says that nine out of ten good people who die, good purgatory.
Why?
Because of impurities.
If you go to a place that makes things in gold or silver or anything else, they will
tell you that if the gold is impure, it loses enormous amount of its value, so they have
to purify it, absolutely.
That's why the Bible talks about being purified like gold in the furnace.
So what we're actually talking about here is a major subject, not only in Louisa, but
also in the Bible itself, all right?
And the Lord is going to tell us that we need an enormous amount of purification in
our lifetime, because half the time you don't see the impurities that you have yourself,
in your motivation and all this kind of stuff.
We can have impurities in our desires and all the rest of it.
At these words, the soul feels a divine purity enter into her.
Now a divine purity is something so high, so immaculate.
You see, if you go to divine purity, you have to use the word immaculate, you hear it?
That the person is completely changed.
This purity is transmuted into herself, and she arrives at living as if no longer in
a body.
In other words, she is spiritualized.
And so with the other virtues, all how desirable are these words of Jesus?
As for myself, I would give anything that is on the earth if I could possess it.
And it causes even one of these words of Jesus.
So number four, the fourth way in which Jesus communicates to me is when I find myself inside
of myself in the natural state, she's no longer in ecstasy.
This also happens in two ways.
The first one is when, while being inside myself recollected within the interior of my
heart, without articulation of voice or sound to the ear of the body, Jesus speaks interiorly.
Now they're called interior locutions, and that's quite common with people living a
spiritual life.
It's not unusual at all when you're speaking to spiritual people, that they will say the
Lord said to me.
And they may have, they use those words, and they may not have heard them as distinct words,
but yet the message has been communicated very clearly, it's actually quite common.
The second is just the way we do it, in other words, there is words.
And sometimes this happens when I am distracted, or I'm speaking to other people, so she needs
to have the words in her ears.
But one of these words is enough to make me recollect myself if I'm distracted and to
give me peace if I am disturbed.
And what she's done there is a great service, and the priests began to realize that this
needed to be explained, because she was having such profound experience of God.
With all the study I've done on this thing, I have come to the conclusion that it was
the bishop who insisted on the priest asking her because the church had actually got very,
very interested in what was happening with this person.
So that was an interlude, and now she continues from the story from a few pages back.
So I will continue where I left off, she said.
And this is how he did it.
In the morning I went to communion, and as soon as I received Jesus, I immediately said
to him, "My Lord, look at what a storm I find myself in.
I should thank you for you gave light to the confessor in giving me the obedience to suffer.
But instead my nature is so very affected that I myself remain confused at seeing myself
so bad."
Now, the word "so bad" there, she will use them in the early volumes.
The Italian word is "cativa."
And if you translated it into English, it's your naughty little thing.
Because if she's bad in the sense of having sin, then forget about union with God, forget
about divine will.
You cannot have union with God or divine will if they're sin in your soul, even venials
and you can't have it.
So when she says I'm so bad, she's looking at this divine purity and comparing the weakness
of human nature with this divine purity, there's just no comparison.
So that's why she will use that expression.
However, this is nothing.
You who want the sacrifice will also give me the strength.
Now, do you know what she's talking about?
I'm asking you a question.
Do you know what she's talking about?
So what you do to find out what she's talking about is go back a few pages before she was
teaching you about how the Lord speaks to her.
You go back a few pages and was there, she was telling you a story.
And then she interrupted it and gave you this teaching and now she's continuing.
So it's that story that she wants to tell you about.
So let's go back, unfortunately my pages are half the size of yours.
She was saying that she had told the priest that the Lord wanted her to be in bed for
a very short time, about 40 days, do you remember that?
Yeah, because he wanted her to suffer.
That was the thing.
So she's picking up on that, all right?
And she said, I should thank you for you gave light to the confessor in giving me the obedience
to suffer.
So the priest has told her it's okay to be a victim's soul.
But instead my nature is so very affected that I myself remain confused and seeing myself
the way I am.
However, all this is nothing.
You who want the sacrifice will give me the strength.
Now, that's the sacrifice to stay in bed.
She has no idea that she's going to be in that bed for 64 years.
If she knew that she just couldn't do it.
And beside that, I want to give you Sam 40 verses 6 to 8.
Here I am.
You want this sacrifice.
So that's Sam 40 verses 6 to 8.
And Hebrews 10 verses 5 to 7, again speaking about the sacrifice.
And that's the sacrifice of your own body.
Now if you don't think it was a sacrifice to sit in bed for 64 years, I think you don't
know what we're talking about.
I would have gone mad after a week.
I don't know about you.
So he and he tells her in higher volumes when she's sort of needing a bit of reassurance.
He says, look, everybody will know that a person in the whole of their health cannot
sit in a bed for all the years that you've sat in a bed.
It has to be a miracle.
It's one of the signs.
And so if you look in the mirror, you see whatever you see, but you don't see what other
people say.
They see something different.
So she can't see herself.
But the strongest reason in me is that of having to remain so long without being able
to receive you in the sacrament.
That means the whole Eucharist.
So Louisa is presuming that if she stays in bed, she won't have the Blessed Eucharist
and she won't have mass.
That's because she's only at the beginning.
They will in fact bring a little altar into her bedroom in the end and same as there.
Who would be able to resist without you?
Resist means put up with the sheer tedium of sitting in a bed, apparently doing nothing.
Who will give me the strength?
Where will I find a refreshment in my afflictions?
And while saying this, I felt such pains in my heart because of this separation from
Jesus in the Most Holy Eucharist that I cried my heart out.
Then the Lord, compassionating is not a word that we use, sympathizing with my weakness
told me, "Do not fear, I myself will sustain your weakness."
So that's Philippians 4, 13, "I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength."
You do not know what grace is I have prepared for you and even when she begins to get them,
she just can't believe it.
And this is why you fear so much.
Am I not omnipotent, Psalm 89.8, 1 John 4.18, Psalm 89.8, 1 John 4.18.
Will I not be able to make up for the privation of being able to receive me in the Holy Eucharist?
Therefore, resign yourself, place yourself as though dead in my arms, that's Psalm 131.
My soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap.
Offer yourself as it have to put in a voluntary victim to repair for the offenses against
me.
So the Lord is asking her to be a voluntary victim soul and to make reparation for others,
for sinners and to spare human beings the deserved scourges.
And as a pledge, I give you my word, now this is God speaking, okay, that I will not leave
you even one day without coming to see you.
That will not be found in any other biography of any other person on this planet.
It's totally off the Richter scale.
Up until now, you have come to me from now on, I will come to you, aren't you happy?
Isn't that amazing?
It's really amazing.
So I want to give you a heading for the next section and it's the graces that she received.
He told her he was preparing great graces for her.
So step one was I resigned myself to the Holy Will of God.
That's the first stage without the resignation we're going nowhere.
And that resignation means that whatever it is that you're suffering from, that you adore
the divine dispositions in your life.
You have allowed this to happen to me, whether by your direct will or your permissive will,
it doesn't matter.
I'm not going to look at it.
You've allowed this to happen to me.
I adore and praise and accept and bless you for this.
I enter into it.
That's it.
She has a completely different place to people at a much earlier stage in the spiritual life
where at the moment they get any trouble, they run after people to pray with them, to get
out of it.
It's totally different.
You're in a much, much higher place.
So the first step then is this surrender.
And I was surprised by this stage of sufferings.
Now, who can tell the graces that the Lord began to give to me?
It's impossible to tell you everything distinctly.
That's your one Corinthians 2 and 9 again.
I can't say it.
I can only say something confusingly because she has explained that's how it is.
But as much as I can, and in order to do all your obedience which wants it, I will say
as much as it is possible for me.
So the first thing is, I remember that from the very beginning of my being continuously
bedridden, my lover Jesus would make himself seen very often, which he had not done in
the past.
Now, notice she calls him my lover.
It's no longer my redeemer, my Savior, my God, my lover.
It's my lover.
It's a completely different language.
It's the language of the song of songs, and the language of the song of songs is all over
volume one.
From the beginning, he told me that he wanted me to take on a new way of life right D.W.
beside that, and that was to live in the divine will, that she'll only realize that as she
goes along, in order to dispose myself to that mystical marriage which he promised me.
So she's going to have the mystical marriages and then she's going to be lifted up onto the
level of divine will.
He would say to me, "Beloved of my heart, I have put you in this state so that I might
come more freely to converse with you.
See I have freed you of all external occupations."
This is one of the things that's important for understanding volume one, to distinguish
what is it that applies to Louisa alone and what applies to the rest of us.
He was being asked to live in a bed completely isolated from normal life because of the extraordinary
calling that she had.
You are not called to that.
So for the extraordinary things that apply just to that situation doesn't apply to you.
So I've freed you of all external occupations so that not only your soul but also your body
might be at my disposal because her body is going to go through all kinds of sufferings.
And so that you might remain in continuous Holocaust.
Look at the word Holocaust before me.
See had I not drawn you into this bed you would have had to carry out your family duties
and submit yourself to other sacrifices and I could not come as often and let you share
the offenses just as I received them.
Now what she's going to do, what the Lord's going to do with her is as he receives offenses
from the earth.
He wants her to mitigate them.
It's absolutely extraordinary the way the Lord actually works and when he tells us that
he loves us we very often misunderstand it that he should love us in a lovey dovey way
meaning I hug you and I kiss you and I blah blah blah you know it's not like that.
Here's human beings creating hell for themselves on the earth and he has somebody mitigating
all of that so they won't actually get help and there's some possibility of recovery.
That's infinite love, that's loving us beyond our ability to even understand what love is.
And when you're reading this you're not just hearing this extraordinary relationship between
Louisa and Jesus you're hearing this extraordinary relationship between Jesus and the human race.
And if you just keep remembering what he said in the hour of the Passion in which Jesus
is on the cross at any cost I want to save them, at any cost I want to save them.
So he's going to bring Louisa into a position of at any cost I want to save them because
he tells her that her life is to be a mirror of his in everything which is totally extraordinary.
So you will share in these offenses just as I received that means daily.
At most I would have to wait for when you have fulfilled your duties well of course
if you weren't in the bed I'd have to wait until you were ready.
Now I don't know if you've read any of the writings of Louisa of Vasula Reden, Irish
people call her right and for some reason or other, Reden is her name and the Lord has
to wait until her family duties are finished and then he says now come and that's what
he's saying to Louisa.
If you were still committed to family life and that kind of thing I'd have to wait until
your family duties were done and then we could talk but he doesn't have to do it here.
But now we are free that is you and I are free and there's no one left who may bother
us or interrupt our conversation.
It's called solitude, S-O-L-I-T-U-D-E and solitude means alone with the alone as a solitude is.
From now on my afflictions will be yours and yours will be mine.
My sufferings will be yours and yours will be mine.
My constellations will be yours and yours will be mine.
This is the real victim soul.
We will unite all things together and you will take an interest in my things as if they
were your own and so will I do with yours.
Between the two of us there will be no longer this is mine and this is yours.
Isn't that fantastic?
Yes, you're John 14-21 again.
You and me and I in you.
Everything will be in common on both sides.
I also have Matthew 6-33 there.
So I'll give you a heading for the next paragraph which is the Lord's desire for intimacy.
Because that's what love is.
God is love and love always seeks union, doesn't it?
And love always seeks intimacy.
Do you know how I acted with you?
He said like a king when he wants to speak with his queen's spouse and she is with other
ladies on other affairs.
What does the king do?
He takes her and brings her into his own room, you'd have to add the word OWM.
They close the door so that no one may go in and interrupt their conversation and hear
their secrets.
And so once they are alone they communicate their constellations and their reflections
to each other.
Now if some imprudent person went to knock shouting from behind the door and did not leave
them alone to enjoy their conversation do you think the king would take that as an offence?
That's the way I am with you he said.
And in the same way I would be displeased if someone wanted to remove you from this state.
Is that beautiful?
Yeah.
So heading for the next section is the program for this new relationship.
Because there is a program, there's a way of life.
He continued to tell me, from you I want perfect, that's 100% conformity to my will.
This is the plan.
Now perfect conformity means there will be none of your will.
You won't have plans of your own.
In such a way that your will may be undone in mine, your will won't be operating.
She will call this annihilation and all kinds of things.
And I want absolute detachment from everything.
Now if you don't think that's a tall order try detaching yourself from something you like.
So much so that I want all that is of earth to be considered by you as dung and rot.
That doesn't mean it is dung and rot but you're to consider it as if it was.
All you're being told is you give your full 100 attention to me.
But that's all lovers ever want, is it?
Do they want you to be distracted with other relationships?
No, they don't.
They go mad don't they?
So and this because even though one were not attached to earthly things just by having
them around them and looking at them they cast a shadow on celestial things.
Now good people need to look at that.
I presume all everybody in the room is good.
That the very fact of being surrounded by all of this stuff actually does affect you.
So I'm going to throw something out and I probably won't say it again.
And that is gradually you've got to let go of the black box.
It's doing terrible damage to everybody.
There was a a nun I think he was in the 18th century who got a vision and they all the
church knew about our vision was that it was terribly important but none of them understood
it and they said we will keep the memory and they wrote it down.
And the vision was this she said I see a family a father and mother and children sitting in
front of a black box and the black box is destroying them.
And the only thing the church knew was something was going to be invented that would destroy
family life.
By that interesting.
Now there are some useful things on it but we just have to be very, very, very careful
because that's what the Lord says.
Even if you are detached it can affect you.
And it can affect you even just by putting a worldly kind of haze on things and you lose
the sharpness of the spirit and that's very dangerous when you're really trying to get
into divine will.
So just by having them around them they cast a shadow on celestial things because all the
stuff, even the news, I mean the only thing I watch is the news and even the news I mean
is so contaminated because it's totally contaminated with a worldly thinking that is completely
contrary to the way the Lord wants us to think, well at the same time you do need to
know what's going on on the planet.
So that's casting a shadow over celestial things and prevent the fulfillment of that
mystical marriage that I promised you.
Even more I want that just as I was poor you would also imitate me in poverty.
Now there's nothing poorer than sitting in a bed and owning nothing.
You know I have no control over water or food or anything else coming to you.
You must consider yourself in this bed as a poor little one and she will refer to herself
as a poor little one for the rest of the time.
The poor are content with anything they have and they first thank me and then their benefactors
now it's to be the same for you.
So go along with everything that's given to you without asking for this and that whoops.
Try it and they'll give you the only dinners you don't like and they'll offer you the
only things you don't want and all the rest of it and this will really test you and that's
how you will know.
So if you're right on your book right know self will.
That's what he's asking know self will and the motto you have to have once you begin this
journey into divine will the motto is as clear as daylight not my will but dine be done and
every time something crosses you just try and get it out of you as soon as you can not
my will even sometimes I just say it out loud so that I hear it he doesn't need to hear
as I do to make sure that I I've adjusted myself you know that I'm not having a problem
with something that I would have had a problem with before same for you to go along with
everything that's given to you without asking for this or that which might be a hindrance
to your mind notice he doesn't want a hindrance to your mind what's going on in the world
today is the contamination of the human brain and they're trying to seduce the people's thinking
into a way of thinking this totally anti God anti Christ that's what's going on and it's
mind control they're trying to use through all these gadgets you have no idea they've
managed very well with the iPhone to mind control millions of people they're totally addicted
to this gadget totally addicted and unfortunately they get addicted before the 15 and as far as
I'm concerned they very little chance unless somebody takes it out of their hands but with
wholly indifference without thinking of whether it may be good or bad comply with the will
of others now if you try that one you'll be well exercised Louisa said this cost me very
much at the beginning and we all say ditto especially because of the obedience is that
the confessor would give me I don't know why he wanted me to take cringing see the doctors
think there's something wrong with her that and for some unknown reason they gave her
quinine and I deliberately say some unknown reason because they tried quinine on us in
Africa to try and counteract some of the stuff quinine is not an easy thing to take and as
side effects but on someone who was eating as little as she was it must have been devastating
and I was given the obedience that as many times as I would throw up because her stomach
wouldn't take it so many times was that I take food again now quinine would wet the
appetite that might be the only good thing it would do and sometimes I would feel quite
a bit hungry I would take food and immediately after taking it and at times in the very act
of taking it I would be forced to bring it back up because of the continuous retching
and I would remain with the same hunger as before the word poor which Jesus had spoken
to me would not allow me to dare to ask for anything and I myself would feel ashamed
to ask thinking to myself what will the family say she has just vomited and now she wants
to eat now what she is beginning to learn is the long fast of being a victim soul and
she describes it so simply somebody else would say it to you in highfalutin words that it
doesn't take the pain away the fasting costs but she's speaking in a very child like way
and she says you know I was hungry of course you're hungry if you're fasting so I would
remain content with being able to offer something to my dear Jesus and the thing she's offering
is hunger however this didn't last a very long time only four months can you imagine
being practically starving for four months one day the Lord told me repeat to him the
request for the obedience not to take Quinean because Quinean was very bad for her and
not to take food so many times for I will give him light that's enlightenment so the
confessor came and I told him and he said to me so it's not to show uniqueness oh dear
people use the most crazy motivations we don't want you to be unique everybody's unique
you may be like somebody else but doesn't know what person has been duplicated the Lord
has this extraordinary variety on the planet we don't want you to be unique from now on
I want you to take food only once a day and he suspended the Quinean also well at least
you was only going to have to vomit once a day in this way I remained more quiet and
hunger went away now once they would stop interfering the Lord actually supplied her
needs okay but the vomiting did not cease that one time in which I would take food I
was forced to bring it up sometimes the Lord told me to ask for the obedience not to eat
but the confessor has never given me this obedience he would say to me it doesn't matter if you
throw it up it's another mortification wonderful isn't it but I would say to Jesus and he would
tell me I want you to ask the question but with holy indifference I want you to go along
with whatever the obedience says to you the obedience is the priest you see and she said
that's what I did and for about 40 days this went on that's more than six weeks I don't
know how you would react that I've been gone mad already would you which I had taken as
much from those words that the Lord had said for a certain given time she thought she was
only going to be in bed for about six weeks and which I had related to the confessor in
this way the sufferings continued to surprise me every day surprise me means she didn't
bring it on and he was forced to come every day the confessor began to give me the obedience
to no longer be in that state now if you the priest is getting a bit fed up coming every
day to just make a sign of blessing over this woman and then she loosens up so he began
to give me the obedience to no longer be in that state and he added that if I fell into
sufferings he would come no more now that's a threat now here's the priest not realizing
that he's up against the Lord he's not really up against Louisa and so the next paragraph
I wanted to put a heading in at the cost of being in bed because you have to know really
cost her on my part I felt absolutely ready to do the obedience my nature especially wanted
to be freed from being in bed continuously in other words it was so boring it was so
tedious because as beautiful as it was it was always bed it's the way she puts it having
to be subjected to everyone even in the most repugnant and necessary things of nature like
if she has to be in bed she's gonna have to be washed in bed and everything you know and
being forced to tell them to others it's a true sacrifice so nature that is her human
nature did its office of wanting to complain and felt all consoled in receiving disobedience
while my soul was ready to do the obedience and ready to remain in bed if the Lord wanted
it so because I had begun to experience how good he had been to me and that true resignation
can change the nature of things from bitter to sweet would you underline that in green
white and gold that is definitely for you and me it's from her experience but it's
given for all of us that if we are resigned to the Lord something that is bitter as an
experience the Lord will change it just by your resignation alone it turns bitter into
sweet so when he gave me the obedience to no longer to stay in bed I began to resist
so now she's told to get out of bed and I said to the Lord what can I do I can no longer
stay for obedience doesn't want it that means the priest doesn't want it if you want you
give enlightenment to the confessor and then I will be ready to do whatever you want so
not my will but dying can you see it and I spent one entire night clashing with the Lord
do you remember Jacob and the angel when he would come I would say to him my dear Jesus
have patience do not come for obedience does not permit that you make me share in your
sufferings up until morning I won to their Jacob and the angel and then the angel wins
the battle doesn't he I felt I was inside myself and free of sufferings when in one instant
the Lord came and drew me so much to himself that I couldn't resist him I lost consciousness
that means going to ecstasy and I found myself together with him but so class to him such
that much much opposition as I made I could not attach myself from Jesus being with Jesus
I felt all and I elated and I felt a certain blushing for the many reproaches that I had
made during the night and I said to him holy spouse forgive me it's the confessor that
wants it this way and he told me don't worry don't fear when it is because of obedience
I don't get offended I love the expression do you in other words if it's somebody else
ordering it but if it's your own thing it's different and he said come come to me today
is the new year I want to give you a present that interesting this morning was in fact the
new year she says so he drew his most pure lips to mine and poured a most sweet milk in
now in these recollections she speaks about receiving a milk from the Lord it's called
milk because it appears to be white many of the mystics say the same thing but I don't
understand it I don't know what is actually going on so I can't explain it and the only
decent thing for a teacher to do is to admit the ignorance as well another thing she gets
every now and then is what she calls a liqueur and it's bitter and somehow the Lord is communicating
something and all I can say to you is watch what happens when she gets the milk and watch
what happens when she gets the liqueur and then you yourself can come to a conclusion
in other words I'm trying to guide you to get from the text itself what is what is happening
so he kissed me he took a ring from within his side and he said to me today I want to
show you the ring I have prepared for you for when I espouse you that means when I marry
you and then he told me tell the confessor that it is my will that you continue to stay
in bed and as a sign that it is me tell him that there is a war between Italy and Africa
and if he gives you the obedience to continue to suffer I will not do anything on either
side they will reconcile so here's the Lord now giving a strong indication to the priest
that it is in fact himself that wants Louisa to stay in bed so he has to give the priest
a piece of information that he knows and he knows that Louisa doesn't know in the very
act of saying these words you're spoken I felt surrounded by sufferings as by a garment
and I was unable to free myself by myself I talked to myself oh what do the confessor
say but it was no longer in my power that milk watch this now that Jesus had poured into
me produced in me such love for him that I felt langer now you find that in the song
of songs chapter three is around verse four or further on where the bride says feed me
with apples because I am sick with love so the milk is feeding divine love into her
why it comes the reason why I can't explain it is that I've never come across an explanation
as to why it's this thought has just come to me this minute so it's obviously somebody
trying to help me to help you and that is yeah I've never thought of it what the Lord
seems to be saying is look at her mother and child the very first thing she does is to
feed the child with milk she's giving her own substance and you've just read that Louisa
said I was filled with so much love my substance he said his love there you have it from himself
you'll be simple because I admitted the truth and he does that sometimes in the class as
well he just gives to me directing so she feels this this incredible love actually given to her
so that I felt langer she said and I felt such satiety and sweetness you see and the child does
as well after sucking from the mother's breast that after the confessor came and I came around
from that state and the family brought me food I felt so full that the food would not even go down
in other words this infilling of let me write this down in the case I forget
because if he gives you something you shouldn't forget it she has been filled so much by the Lord
that her body has no needs now that's going to be her reality for 64 years that he will
actually sustain her completely and she gets it here for the first time so after the confessor
came I was so full that the food wouldn't go down but in order to do the obedience which
wanted it so I took a little bit and I was immediately forced to bring it up but mixed with that sweet
milk that Jesus had given me so for the first time the priest has evidence that when she says she
received milk from the Lord that it is actually real now I want you to write down just beside that
evidence for the priest and look how kind the Lord is he's you don't you can't expect the
priest to understand something he hasn't seen before but she said she received milk and that
she's full with it and now the food comes back with the milk as well Jesus almost jokingly told me
so what I gave you isn't enough john 6 35 are you not content yet I blushed all over but
immediately I said to him what can I do it's obedience I love the way she says that it's not
my problem it's the priest so when the confessor came he began to get upset telling me that I was
disobedient or he would say to me this is an illness if it were something from God he would
have made you obey in other words the priest is following what they have known from the past about
ordinary situations he would expect that the Lord would force her to obey but the Lord is trying
to get the priest to open up to something completely new therefore instead of calling the confessor
you should call the doctors when he finished speaking I told him everything that the Lord had said to
me which I mentioned above and he told me that it was true that there was a war in between Africa
and Italy we'll see if nothing happens he says and so he was persuaded in letting me continue to
suffer she had to give him that piece of information to try and tell him that there's something real
going on so one day after about four months one of the things that impresses me hugely is how long
her trials go on the confessor came and told me that news had arrived about the war between
Africa and Italy and that without causing any damage to each other they had reconciled so
since the sign was accurate the prophecy was complete the confessor was persuaded and he let
me stay there in peace in other words he had received a true prophecy that's that's so just
right beside it this is a true prophecy now while she's having a lot of difficulty with the priests
and that kind of thing at the same time you have got to have a lot of compassion for the priests
they've never been in this situation before how are they to know that this isn't some kind of a
mental illness so the heading for the next paragraph is daily visits from the Lord he had promised her
he would come didn't he my sweet Jesus would do nothing but dispose me to that mystical marriage
which he had promised me and when I was in that state he would make me seen sometimes make himself
seen three or four times a day absolutely unprecedented talk about uniqueness the priest didn't want her
to be unique just as he pleased and sometimes it was a continuous coming and going in other words
she had heaven on earth it seemed he seemed to be a sweetheart who couldn't be without his spouse
this is how Jesus was with me and sometimes he reached the point of telling me you see I love you
so much that I cannot be without coming there's a lovely level in which you can just look at this
as a real genuine love relationship but on the other hand if you realize she's the only person
on the planet who loves them like this she doesn't want to be comes you can't believe it somebody on
the planet loves him like this and he's going to take her to heaven more than once and say to the saints
look at the way she loves me nobody else loves me like this nobody at all not even them when they
were on the earth loved him like this he said I feel almost restless thinking that you are there
suffering from me and you're all alone and this is why I've come to see if you need something
it's a real lover situation isn't it and while he was saying this he himself would lift my head he
would place his arm around my neck and hug me that's song of songs to six his left arm under my head and
his right arm embracing me song of songs to six and while holding me like that he would kiss me
and if it were summertime it was hot he would send a refreshing breath from his mouth and he would
take something in his hand and he would fan may imagine and then he would ask me how are you feeling
don't you feel better I would say to him being with you in whatever way one feels grand thanks
other times then if he saw me very weak because of my continuously being in those suffering because
that's why he said he would come very frequently if she would continue in them especially if the
confessor was coming at night my lover Jesus would come and in seeing me in that state of extreme
weakness to the point that at times I felt I was dying he would draw near me and from his
mouth he would pour milk into mine there you have it again but I want to give you a song of songs
too far or he would place me close to his side and from there I would suckle torrents of sweetness
that's Sam 36 verse 8 you drink from the torrents of his delight so if the Sam says you could drink
from the torrents of his delight it means that from ancient times people knew that if you came
close to the Lord it is the delights of heaven that you actually taste and the awful thing is that
the the world has deceived millions of people into thinking that very low things and ephemeral
things will give you delight and it doesn't it doesn't delight them at all so she's already
experiencing the torrents of sweetness and delight and end of strength now that strength is physical
mental emotional and spiritual it's the whole thing and he would say to me I really want
to be your everything now that's lover language isn't it and also your nourishment not only for
the soul but also for the body that means that he himself wants to be her sustainer and she says
who can tell me what I experienced both in the soul and in the body from these graces that Jesus
would give me if I wanted to tell them it would be too long I remember that sometimes when he would
not come quickly I would lament to him saying oh please oh holy spouse how could you make me wait
so long she probably waited about 10 minutes the rest of his way to lifetime I could not resist
anymore I felt I was dying without you and while saying this the pain I felt was such that I would
cry and he would sympathize with me he would dry my tears he would kiss me he would hug me and he
would say I don't want you to cry Isaiah 25 verse 8 Isaiah 25 verse 8
Revelation 7 17 that's where he will dry our tears forever and Revelation 22 4 again the
Lord says he will dry our tears in other words that sorrow will end see I am with you now
and tell me what you want I would say to him I want nothing but you that's Deuteronomy 6 4
you shall love the Lord your God with all your heart all your soul and all your mind and all your
being and only then I want nothing but you and only then will I stop crying when you promise me
that you will not make me wait for so long and he would say to me yes yes I'll make you content
I'm going to stop there for tonight. It's wonderful stuff isn't it?